Okay Michael so let me take you back to the pseudo code
that we, we have for MIMIC and see if we can plugin some
of the stuff that we we just talked about just as a way
of refreshing. So as you recall, the goals to generate samples from some
Pea soup theta sub T of X. So in this case were just
going to estimate that by finding the best dependency tree we can, that is
the best Pi function, okay? So we're going to be starting with some dependency
tree And we're going to generate samples from that, and we know how to
generate samples from that given a dependency tree
like say this. We simply started a
node, generate according to it's unconditional distribution and
then generate samples from each according to it's
conditional distribution given it's parents. So, first we
generate a sample from here. Then we
generate one from here, then from here, then
from here, and then from here. Now where
do we get these conditional probability tables, Michael?
>> That's a good question. I think
it's pretty direct from the mutual information.
>> Exactly. In order to compute
the mutual information, that is in order to compute the
entropies, we have to know the probabilities. So, we generate
all of these samples, and that tells us now, for
every single feature, X of I, how often that was say,
taking on a value of one, or taking on a
value for zero. If we assume everything's binary. So that means
we have unconditional probability distributions. Or at least estimates of
unconditional probability distributions, for every
single one of our features, yes?
>> Yep.
>> And
at the same time, because we have these samples, we know
for every pair of features. The probability that one took on a
value, given a value for the other. So, already have the
conditional probability table for each of those as well. So, just the
act of generating these samples and building that mutual information graph,
gives us all the conditional and unconditional probability tables that we need.
So given that we can generate samples and time linear and
the number of features, and we're done. So this part is easy.
By the way you asked me a question before. I
just want to make it clear, that we come back with an
undirected graph. And, you can pick any single node as the
root, and that will induce a specific directed tree. And it
actually just follows from the chain rule. I'll leave that
as an, an exercise to the, the viewer. But there you
go. So now we know how to generate samples. From some
tree that we have. We generate a bunch of these samples.
We find the best ones. Retaining only those samples, and now we know
how to estimate the next one, by simply doing the maximum spanning tree over
all the mutual information. And then we just repeat. And we keep doing it.
And there you go. A particular version of mimic. With dependency trees. Got it?
>> Cool.
>> Right. So, again, just to really drive this point home,
you don't have to use dependency trees. You can use unconditional
probability distributions, which are also very easy to sample from and
very easy to estimate. You could come up with more complicated things,
if you wanted to. Try to find the best Bayesian network. You
can do all of these other kinds of things and that'll work
just fine. Dependency Trees though are very powerful, because they do
allow you to capture these relationships, that is to say they give
you a probability distribution that has structure that we were looking for,
while not having to pay an exponential cost for doing the estimation.